♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
AFTER THREE TRIES, MORE THAN
THREE DECADES OF ATTEMPTING IT,
JOE BIDEN LAST NIGHT FINALLY GOT
HIS PARTY’S NOMINATION.
A YEAR AGO, VIRTUALLY NO ONE
WOULD’VE PREDICTED THIS MOMENT,
FOR MOST OF THE LONG PRIMARY
SEASON, HE FLOUNDERED NEAR THE
BOTTOM OF A CROWDED FIELD, HE
GOT SO FEW VOTES IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, HE DIDN’T BOTHER
WITH THE CONCESSION SPEECH, HE
TRIED TO PRETEND IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
IN THE END, HE WON ANYWAY, THE
LAST KID PICKED FOR KICKBALL
WOUND UP CAPTAIN OF THE TEAM.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF HIM,
THAT’S AN UNDENIABLE
ACHIEVEMENT, AND YET STILL NOW
VERY FEW PEOPLE TAKE HIM
SERIOUSLY -- IF YOU SEE HIM
TALK, HE IS.
IT’S NOT A PARTISAN POINT, IT’S
NOT INTENDED TO BE COOL, IT’S
TRUE.
AT 70-YEAR-OLDS ARE NOT MEANT TO
LEAD TO LARGE COUNTRIES, IT IS
OLD AGE.
BIGGER DECLINES OVER THE COURSE
OF A LIFETIME, PARTICULARLY IN
MEN.
JOE BIDEN HAS GROWN WEEK, THAT’S
WHY WE DON’T TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY.
IT TURNS OUT THERE’S ANOTHER WAY
TO LOOK AT HIS DECLINE, A
PERSPECTIVE THAT HASN’T OCCURRED
TO MOST REPUBLICANS BUT AT THE
CENTER OF DEMOCRAT SELECTION
STRATEGY.
HE’S SLOWING DOWN, HE HAS
TROUBLE STARTING SENTENCES, HE
FORGETS WORDS, OCCASIONALLY HE
MISTAKES HIS SISTER FOR HIS
WIFE.
EVERY TIME HE GETS CONFUSED, HE
GRINS AND THAT CHARMINGLY OLD
PEOPLE DO WHEN THEY KNOW THEY
ARE LOSING IT, SO YES, JOE BIDEN
HAS GOTTEN A LITTLE DAFFY BUT
FOR THAT VERY REASON, HE’S NOT
GOING TO HURT YOU.
THERE IS NOTHING THREATENING
ABOUT HIM, HE’S NOT AGGRESSIVE
OR OVERLY AMBITIOUS.
IN A TIME OF CHAOS AND A
SHOUTING, IT MIGHT BE COMFORTING
TO BE LED BY A MAN WHO TALKS
ABOUT RECORD PLAYERS AND WEAR
SLIPPERS WITH SOCKS ATTACHED --
THAT’S THE ACTUAL MESSAGE, THE
SUBTEXT OF THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
NO ONE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WILL SAY IT ALOUD, NO ONE EVER
WILL BUT HIS HANDLERS UNDERSTAND
THAT HIS PUNCHING US COULD BE
HIS BIGGEST ASSET.
BECAUSE HE’S SO OBVIOUSLY
INEFFECTIVE, HE’S HARMLESS.
BECAUSE HE IS PASSIVE, YOU
ASSUME HE’S WELL-MEANING.
YOU WOULDN’T PUT HIM IN CHARGE
OF YOUR DINNER RESERVATION BUT
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU’RE NOT
GOING TO SEND THEM TO AN
INTERNMENT CAMP.
HE’S THE MIRROR IMAGE OF
ELIZABETH WARREN, HER EYES GLEAM
WITH THE PROMISE OF GERMANIC
EFFICIENCY.
BIDEN’S EYES, THERE’S NOTHING
THERE, JUST A PASSIVE VOID.
DEMOCRATS SEE AN ADVANTAGE LIKE
THIS, A PARTY THAT NO LONGER
REPRESENTS THE MAINSTREAM NEEDS
A LEADER WHO WON’T SCARE
BOATERS, HIS JOB IS TO SOOTHE
YOUR FEARS ABOUT WHAT THE LEFT
WILL DO IF THEY EVER TAKE POWER.
STACY ABRAMS OR BETO O’ROURKE
COULD NEVER DO THAT, THEIR PLANS
ARE TOO OBVIOUS, JOE BIDEN HAS
NO PLAN.
THE MOST RADICAL MASS POLITICAL
MOVEMENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY HAS
FOUND A FRONT MAN WHO SEEMS LIKE
HE SHOULD BE FEEDING PIGEONS.
DEMOCRATS ARE HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU DIDN’T SEE IT BIDEN SPEAK
LAST NIGHT, YOU MAY NOT FULLY
APPRECIATE THIS DYNAMIC.
AT SOME REPUBLICANS IN
WASHINGTON WILL TELL YOU HIS
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH WAS SCARY,
IT’S THEIR JOB TO SAY THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT IN THIS CASE,
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
WATCH THIS CLIP AND ASK YOURSELF
WHAT YOU DISAGREE WITH.
>> WHILE I’LL BE A DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE, I WILL BE AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT.
I’LL WORK HARD FOR THOSE WHO
DIDN’T SUPPORT ME, AS HARD FOR
THEM AS I DID FOR THOSE WHO DID
VOTE FOR ME.
THAT’S THE JOB OF A PRESIDENT,
TO REPRESENT ALL OF US, NOT JUST
OUR BASE OR OUR PARTY.
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN MOMENT,
THIS MUST BE AN AMERICAN MOMENT.
IT’S A MOMENT THAT CALLS FOR
HOPE AND LIGHT AND LOVE, HOPE
FOR OUR FUTURE, LIKE TO SEE OUR
WAY FORWARD, AND LOVE FOR ONE
ANOTHER.
AMERICA ISN’T JUST A COLLECTION
OF CLASHING INTERESTS OF RED
STATES OR BLUE STATES, WE ARE SO
MUCH BIGGER THAN THAT.
>> Tucker: AN AMERICAN MOMENT,
AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT, AN
AMERICAN LEADER WHO REPRESENTS
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF PARTY.
A COLLECTION OF CLASHING
INTERESTS, A FUTURE OF HOPE AND
LOVE FOR FELLOW AMERICANS.
THAT’S WHAT HE PROMISED LAST
NIGHT -- IS THERE ANYONE WHO
DOESN’T WANT THAT?
THE LEADERS OF HIS PARTY FOR ONE
THING.
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD DOES NOT
REPRESENT THE DNC’S VISION FOR
AMERICA, IT’S NOT EVEN CLOSE.
READ THEIR PLATFORM, WATCH THEIR
SPEECHES -- WE SPENT ALL WEEK
DOING IT.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS ARE NOT
CALLING FOR UNITY, THEY ARE
DEMANDING DIVISION.
THEY STAGED AN ENTIRE CONVENTION
THAT AMOUNTED TO THE EXTENDED
ATTRIBUTE OF THE ZERO-SUM
VICIOUSNESS OF IDENTITY
POLITICS.
GIVE IT TO US NOW.
A NATION OF 350 MILLION PEOPLE
SPLINTERED INTO COUNTLESS
WARRING TRIBES UNITED BY NOTHING
APART FROM A COMMON LOATHING OF
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
IT WAS AN ORGY OF GRIEVANCE
MONGERING.
WATCH THE REVEREND FREDDY HAYNES
SAYING HATES REPUBLICANS ALSO
MUSCLE.
>> YOU HAVE THE NERVE TO BUILD A
WALL WHILE AT THE SAME TIME YOU
HAVE IN THE HARBOR IN NEW YORK
THE STATUE OF LIBERTY SAYING
GIVE ME YOUR TIRED, HUDDLED
MASSES YEARNING TO BREATHE FREE.
WILL SAY AMERICA, IF YOU DON’T
GET YOUR ACT TOGETHER, YOU MAY
WELL GO TO.
>> Tucker: AMERICA IS HEADED
TO SAYS THE REVEREND.
FRATERNITY, THAT’S NOT
SPECULATION -- IT IS A STRAIGHT
PREDICTION FROM HIMSELF.
ALSO FROM JEREMIAH WRIGHT FROM
CHICAGO.
HE WAS THE SPIRITUAL MENTOR, HE
AND BARACK OBAMA AT THAT IN
COMMON.
HE DIDN’T SPEAK AT THIS WEEK’S
DNC BUT HE WAS CERTAINLY THERE
IN SPIRIT.
KAMALA HARRIS CHANNELED HIM IN
HER PRIME TIME SPEECH, WATCH
HARRIS DIAGNOSED AMERICA WITH A
FATAL CASE OF RACISM.
>> THERE IS NO VACCINE FOR
RACISM.
WE GOT TO DO THE WORK.
FOR GEORGE FLOYD, FOR BREANNA
TAYLOR, FOR THE LIVES OF TOO
MANY OTHERS TO NAME.
WE’VE GOT TO DO THE WORK TO
FULFILL THAT PROMISE OF EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER LAW.
HERE’S THE THING, NONE OF US OUR
FREE UNTIL ALL OF US ARE FREE.
>> Tucker: THERE IS NO
VACCINE, IT LOOKS LIKE THE
PATIENT WON’T MAKE IT, SORRY.
AMERICA IS DYING FROM THE VIRUS
OF RACISM AND THERE’S NOTHING WE
CAN DO, WE’VE REACHED THE LIMITS
OF MODERN MEDICINE.
WE HAVE TO LET THE COUNTRY GO
AND START OVER.
KAMALA HARRIS WAS HARDLY THE
ONLY ONE TO SAY THAT.
SPEAKER AFTER SPEAKER THIS WEEK
HIT THE SAME THEME, AMERICA IS
BEYOND REDEMPTION.
TEAR IT DOWN AND BUILD A NEW
COUNTRY WITH US IN CHARGE.
THERE IS NO VACCINE FOR
AMERICA’S SINS, IT’S TERMINAL.
IT’S UNLIKELY THAT ANY MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTY HAS EVER HAD
SPEAKERS TO SAY ANYTHING LIKE
THIS FROM THE PODIUM.
ATTACKING THE COUNTRY YOU ARE
TRYING TO LEAD AS A RADICAL MOVE
AND IT’S NOT A GOOD WAY TO WIN A
MAJORITY BUT THIS MESSAGE WASN’T
AIMED AT THE MAJORITY, THEY
WOULD RATHER YOU DIDN’T HEAR IT.
THAT’S WHY THEY TROTTED OUT TO
JOE BIDEN.
THE JOB OF THE PRESIDENT IS TO
REPRESENT ALL OF US, NOT JUST
OUR BASE.
EVERYONE IS FOR THAT, AND YET
VIRTUALLY EVERY WORD OF THE
CONVENTION OTHER THAN BIDEN’S
SPEECH WAS AIMED DIRECTLY AT THE
LEFT BASE, THE COALITION OF THE
MISERABLE THAT IS THE ENGINE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HERE IS THE SINGLE DUMBEST
TALKING HEAD ON THE SINGLE
DUMBEST CABLE NEWS CHANNEL
CLAPPING HER HANDS BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS MANAGED TO EXCLUDE AN
ENTIRE RACIAL GROUP, SHE IS
GRATEFUL FOR THAT, SHE COULDN’T
BEAR TO LOOK AT THEM ANYMORE.
>> IT WAS ALL ABOUT
REPRESENTATION, MY LITTLE
MYELINATED CYNICAL HEART, MY
IMMIGRANT HEART FELT SO FULL
LAST NIGHT.
TODAY WITH DAVID AND JOHN IS THE
FIRST TIME I’VE SEEN A WHITE MAN
IN EIGHT HOURS OTHER THAN
JOE BIDEN LAST NIGHT.
THAT’S OKAY, THEY’VE HAD 240
YEARS OF REPRESENTATION, THEY
ARE GOING TO BE OKAY.
>> Tucker: WHAT KIND OF PERSON
WOULD SAY SOMETHING LIKE THAT OR
EVEN THINK IT?
IF YOU EVER CATCH YOURSELF
FEELING THRILLED THAT YOU DON’T
HAVE TO SEE CERTAIN RACIAL
GROUPS, IF YOU FIND PEOPLE WHO
LOOK DIFFERENT FROM YOU THAT
HORRIFYING, THAT REPULSIVE, THEN
YOU CAN BE CERTAIN THAT YOU ARE
INDEED A RACIST, NASTY ONE TOO.
THAT’S EXACTLY THE SORT OF
PERSON THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION WAS AIMED AT.
OUTSIDE THE CONVENTION, THE BASE
STAYED BUSY.
THOUSANDS OF BIDEN VOTERS WORK
TO HELP THE DEMOCRATIC TICKET IN
THE WAY THEY KNOW BEST BY
HURTING PEOPLE AND DESTROYING
THINGS.
[SHOUTING]
[SIRENS]
[BLEEP]
[SHOUTING]
>> Tucker: ANYONE WHO LIVES IN
AN AMERICAN CITY CAN NAVIGATE A
COMPUTER AND KNEW EXACTLY WHAT
WAS GOING ON BUT IF YOU GOT YOUR
NEWS EXCLUSIVELY FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC MESSAGE MACHINE, YOU
WOULD HAVE NO CLUE THAT YOUR
COUNTRY WAS BEING RESHAPED BY
VIOLENCE IN THE STREETS, NO
MENTION OF THAT, ANTIFA WASN’T
ALLOWED TO SEND DELEGATES.
VARIOUS SPEAKERS MADE BLM SOUND
LIKE A BRANCH OF THE UNITED WAY,
THE MEDIA DID NOT CONTRADICT
THIS MESSAGE, THEY REFUSED TO
COVER THE VIOLENCE OUTSIDE, IT
WAS LIKE IT ALL NEVER HAPPENED.
IT’S POSSIBLE THAT JOE BIDEN
NEVER FOUND OUT ABOUT IT, HE
DOESN’T GET OUTSIDE MUCH, HE
KNOWS ONLY WHAT THEY TELL HIM.
JUDGING FROM HIS SPEECH LAST
NIGHT, HE IS COME TO BELIEVE
HE’S MAHATMA GANDHI LEADING A
MOVEMENT TO RESTORE LOVE.
>> WE CAN CHOOSE A PATH BECOMING
ANGRIER, LESS HOPEFUL, MORE
DIVIDED.
A PATH OF SHADOW AND SUSPICION,
OR WE CAN CHOOSE A DIFFERENT
PATH AND TOGETHER TAKE THIS
CHANCE TO HEAL, TO REFORM, TO
UNITE.
A PATH OF HOPE AND LIGHT.
>> Tucker: IT SOUNDS LIKE A
BEATLES LYRIC FROM THEIR ACID
PHASE -- WHO DOESN’T WANT HOPE
AND LIGHT?
ALL DECENT PEOPLE WANT THAT AND
THAT’S WHY IT’S A WINNING
MESSAGE IN A NATIONAL ELECTION.
UNFORTUNATELY IT’S ALSO A DEEPLY
DISHONEST MESSAGE.
UNITY IS NOT WITH THE DEMOCRATS
ARE PROMISING, UNITY IS NOT WHAT
THEY PLAN TO DELIVER.
THE MEDIA UNDERSTANDS THAT VERY
WELL, THEY ARE COMMITTED
DEMOCRATS AS WELL.
HOPE AND LIGHT?
PLEASE.
THESE PEOPLE CHEERED WHEN THEY
THOUGHT ROGER STONE WAS GOING TO
DIE IN PRISON FOR SOME MADE-UP
CRIME.
THEY CRIED WHEN HE WAS SPARED.
THESE ARE HARDENED PARTISANS,
NOT JUST THE ONES WHOSE BROTHERS
ARE SITTING GOVERNORS, THEY KNOW
PERFECTLY WELL WHAT JOE BIDEN
SAID ON STAGE LAST NIGHT WAS
ABSURD BUT THEY ALSO KNOW THAT
MANY AMERICANS WILL BELIEVE IT,
SO THEY LOVED THE SPEECH.
>> IT MAY HAVE BEEN THE BEST
SPEECH THAT JOE BIDEN EVER
DELIVERED.
>> IT’S THE BEST BEACH JOE BIDEN
NEVER DELIVERED.
>> ONE OF THE STRONGEST BEACHES
OF JOE BIDEN’S CAREER.
>> IT WAS PROBABLY THE BEST
SPEECH I EVER HEARD JOE BIDEN
GIVE.
>> WHOEVER WROTE THAT SPEECH
NEEDS TO GET A COOKIE AND A HUG
AND A FLAG AND A PUPPY.
THAT THING WAS CRAFTED SO WELL.
>> HE CAME READY.
>> HE SPOKE PASSIONATELY AND
FROM THE HEART.
>> IT’S A TALE OF TWO VISIONS OF
WHAT THIS COUNTRY IS ABOUT.
ONE IS ABOUT ANGER, JOE BIDEN
GAVE YOU SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT TONIGHT I’M A HE SAID
"I WILL DRAW ON THE BEST OF US."
>> IF I COULD JUMP OUT OF THE
CHAIR, THIS WAS THE BEST NIGHT
FOR JOE BIDEN EVER.
>> Tucker: THE BEST NIGHT FOR
JOE BIDEN EVER!
SHE MIGHT BE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.